(machine guns rattling)
- [Narrator] Israel has
entered what it calls,
"A new phase of its war against Hamas,
with a military advance deep
into the heart of Gaza."
(tank blasting)
Israel has launched ground
invasions of Gaza before,
most recently in 2009 and 2014.
- Israel is at war.
- [Narrator] But this time,
Israeli forces plan to go further
in a multi-phased offensive
into Gaza's sprawling cities
with the aim of destroying
the military capabilities of Hamas,
a US-designated terror group.
(rocket firing)
(gunshots blasting)
Here's a look at how Israeli
ground forces invaded Gaza
in 2009 and 2014,
and what that reveals about
Israel's current operation.
(dramatic music)
(tank blasting)
Israeli ground forces'
most far-reaching military
incursion into Gaza
came during Operation Cast Lead in 2009.
In response to a barrage of Hamas rockets,
thousands of Israeli troops entered Gaza
from the north and east under
the cover of artillery fire.
(gunshots blasting)
The three-week offensive
saw extensive street-to-street fighting
as Israeli ground forces
pushed towards Gaza City
with the aim of taking control
of rocket launch sites,
- You have to understand
the way the Gaza was built.
- [Narrator] Yossi
Kuperwasser is a former head
of Israel's Military
Intelligence Division.
- Between the populated area
and the Israeli territory,
there's an open area.
It's very difficult to move
towards the populated area
because you are totally exposed.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] As soldiers advanced
towards Gaza's major cities,
they reported finding dozens of buildings
booby trapped with explosives
intended to inflict
casualties on Israeli troops.
- That's why we prefer to
prepare the battlefield
by a lot of airstrikes to weaken the enemy
so that when we enter,
their abilities are going to be decimated.
- [Narrator] During the offensive,
the IDF remained on the
outskirts of Gaza's main cities.
This kept Israel's casualties low,
and limited its ability to
target Hamas infrastructure
in built-up areas.
- We didn't mean to take over Gaza.
In 2009, we dealt with the outskirts
of some of the main cities,
but didn't have any intention
to actually enter the center of town.
We didn't put the goal for ourselves,
the uprooting of Hamas from Gaza entirely.
We realized that Hamas is
going to stay in place,
and that was a mistake
because all these rounds
were ended with an agreement
that enabled Hamas to
re-arm itself pretty soon.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] By the
time the operation ended
with Israel's implementation
of a unilateral ceasefire,
1,300 Palestinians and 13
Israelis had been killed.
A UN fact-finding mission found evidence
suggesting both Palestinian
armed groups and Israel
committed actions amounting to war crimes
during the conflict.
Israel's most recent
ground defensive into Gaza
was limited in scope
to destroying aspects
of Hamas infrastructure
in the enclave.
(bomb blasting)
In July 2014,
Israel launched Operation Protective Edge
in response to rockets
and mortar from Hamas.
The Israeli Government initially launched
an aerial operation to
destroy a vast network
of underground tunnels
Hamas had constructed
to store weapons,
including rockets fired
by the group into Israel.
After Hamas, militants used a tunnel
to launch a raid on a
kibbutz in Southern Israel,
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] the government
authorized ground troops
to cross into Gaza with the aim
of destroying cross-border tunnels.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Every attempt to enter the
Gaza Strip on the ground,
it involves, first of all,
anti-tank missiles, mines, booby traps
that are located in places
where you want to enter.
- [Narrator] Israeli troops
and armor pushed into Gaza
in an effort to locate the
entrances to the border tunnels.
During the seven-week operation,
the IDF said, "It discovered
it's 62 miles of tunnels."
- The problem with tunnels
is that you don't see them.
It was not easy for us to locate them,
and we had to have a very
strong intelligence effort
to find out where they are,
and we had to develop a special technique
that would explode them
and make them not function.
(tunnel blasting)
- [Narrator] Israel says, "Its
troops destroyed 32 tunnels,
14 of which infiltrated
into Israeli territory."
(tanks rumbling)
The 2014 conflicts ended
when troops withdrew from Gaza
under a ceasefire agreement
reached at the end of August that year.
- The logic at the time
was that we inflict this heavy
blow on their infrastructure,
cost them a lot of operatives,
and deal harshly with their
rockets-launching capabilities,
to the point that they will ask
for a ceasefire under our conditions.
Sometimes it took longer
and sometimes it took a shorter time
before they resumed
their terror operations,
but they were always capable
of recovering relatively fast.
- [Narrator] The fighting
had killed 2,000 Palestinians
and 72 Israelis.
A United Nations Panel
found evidence indicating war crimes
may have been committed
by both Israel and
Palestinian militant groups
during the conflict.
Israel's previous ground
offensives in Gaza
were much more limited in scope
than what its military
is aiming to do now.
Since Hamas took power in Gaza,
Israel hasn't tried to eliminate
the group's military infrastructure
and leadership in the enclave
- For many, many years,
any of the previous rounds,
we tried not to end up
with taking over Gaza,
but it seems that this time,
we just cannot afford any other solution,
we have to take Gaza
- [Narrator] A ground invasion
with the aim of going into
Gaza's cities to destroy Hamas
presents one of the biggest challenges
the Israeli military has faced in decades.
- This is a dangerous move for any army.
It has to be done slowly and carefully,
and will cost a lot of lives.
(dramatic music)